good morning
um I'd like to
welcome
um
everyone
to this morning's session of the special
committee on the Family Division of the
Circuit Court my name is Marjorie Smith
I'm the vice chair of this committee and
in the absence of the chair I will be
presiding today and
um
our first witness is scheduled
the Bureau of Child Support is first and
we are looking forward to hearing what
you have to say if you could come and
introduce yourselves and
tell us everything we need to know
good morning
um
thank you
um chair uh woman Smith I appreciate the
opportunity for being here today my name
is Lisa decotowski and I am the bureau
chief and the title Roman numeral 4--d
director for the New Hampshire
Department of Health and Human Services
Division of economic stability
and
good morning attorney Matthew Hayes from
the Bureau of Child Support Services I'm
a Staff attorney for the bureau and I
also serve as a legislative liaison
thank you
um so we wanted to take an
we wanted to take an opportunity
and again thank the committee for the
opportunity to speak on behalf of the
Bureau of Child Support Services
understanding that our time here today
is limited we did uh just prepare a
small high-level overview of who the
child support Bureau of Child Support
Services is and just briefly what the
role of the child support program is
here in New Hampshire
and then more importantly for the
committee have an opportunity to speak
to our partnership with the New
Hampshire Circuit Family Division Court
which is uh I will anticipate of
Interest here
and certainly myself and attorney Hayes
are available to answer any questions
either now or for the future
um if the committee needs any further
information from the bureau
um so just to start to sort of level set
the child support program is encourages
responsible parenting Family
self-sufficiency and Child well-being
you know by assisting uh in offering
services to families to help locate
parents to help establish paternity to
help establish and modify and enforce
child support obligations and to obtain
child and medical support for children
so really our goal is to help families
achieve positive outcomes by addressing
the needs and the responsibilities of
parents through the child and medical
support services that our program can
offer them
so our child support program is a
federal state and a tribal partnership
it's established by the Social Security
Act the title Roman numeral 4--d that
seeks to promote economic stability for
children whose parents or caretaker live
apart so we serve families both in state
out of state internationally and within
tribal communities
and our program really Services families
from all socioeconomic backgrounds so
either parent or caretaker May apply for
our services and we are not an
eligibility program
so you know nationally the child support
program is very successful it serves
about one in five children in the United
States about 13.2 million children
Nationwide and on a national level in
federal fiscal year of 2021 the child
support program as a nationally
collected 32.7 billion dollars in child
support money for families in New
Hampshire our program serves
approximately thirty thousand families
and collects about 76 million dollars
in collections annually as of federal
fiscal year of 2021.
so our child support program as I stated
really focuses in on servicing families
single parent households to help them
receive a reliable source of private and
financial medical support services and
when I speak about medical and financial
that again is their appearance financial
responsibility as ordered by the court
through a um through a child support
order and a parent's responsibility to
provide health insurance or medical
medical coverage for their children
so in keeping with that again as I uh
the core functions of our program really
include helping families establish
paternity legal fatherhood or parentage
locating parents The Establishment and
modification and enforcement of the
orders both financial and medical
support collecting and distributing that
support and helping families reduce
barriers to compliance with the those
orders for the success of their children
so
could I interrupt you for a moment
um
if I heard you correctly you said
adjusting the orders in some way so that
is done
in your bailiwick rather and then in the
courts bill
thank you for the question
um so there are two primary if I may
there are two primary areas that the
Bureau of Child Support Services
actually works with the family division
Court one is in the establishment and or
modification of child support orders and
in the enforcement of child support
orders so through our uh primary through
the establishment and or modification
families who apply for and or request
for our services or or their child
support orders who are ordered to be
payable through the child support
services families could ask for our
assistance in helping them to adjust and
modify their orders if it complies with
the current child support guidelines
and if it reaches that opportunity for a
modification
certain families that we work with if
our program identifies an area where an
order may be eligible for review either
every three years
as currently outlined in our guidelines
we will notice our families and give
them an opportunity if they would like
to request our services to assist them
to try to modify their orders but all
the orders in New Hampshire of course
there are multiple types of petitions
and actions brought by the bureau on
behalf of families who have applied for
our services but there are also
circumstances where families bring forth
orders to the court directly that are
considered private action cases that the
Bureau of child support would not
necessarily have involvement in so again
the families we serve are those families
who have ultimately applied for our
services
so in the private action cases those are
typically divorce and parenting
petitions which the court will include a
uniform support order for child and
medical support in those cases but our
Bureau is typically not involved in
those private action cases until after
an order is issued and somebody has
requested for our services to
um either comply or monitor or enforce
that particular order from the court
so as I had mentioned the Bureau of
Child Support Services
works with the bureau excuse me works
with the family division in the two
primary areas and we
um we do that through a Cooperative
agreement with the New Hampshire
Administrative Office of the courts so
the Bureau of Child Support works very
closely with the New Hampshire family
court and the New Hampshire judicial
branch as as we know is the only source
here in New Hampshire that's authorized
to perform these services in New
Hampshire so this partnership that we
have with them really helps us to ensure
that our federally mandated expedited
process program for the establishment
enforcement and the modification of
orders helps to be in compliance with
our title Roman numeral 4D regulations
and through our state plan that we must
have in effect and in use in order to
provide these Services
it allows us to really help to establish
child support orders for families as
quickly as possible because the goal is
that we want to try to assist families
in getting Financial income as quickly
as possible so our we work within our
federal guidelines and time frames to
try to work with our families to get
those orders and get families to agree
to orders if at all possible and then
quickly try to file them with the courts
could you tell us what those timelines
are so the expedited process really
encourages the child support programs to
try to seek an order for establishment
within a 90-day time frame
um and then from there it you know
that's kind of the start we want to try
to get a nine an order in place within
90 days from the date of service of
process to the time of disposition
um and we work hard uh to try to
facilitate that with our families
outside of Court whenever possible
um and then file any agreements that we
can with the court but in if unable to
do so then we have the ability through
our Bureau of child support legal
department uh to file those petitions on
behalf of those families to seek those
orders and and in those circumstances
we're only talking about child support
orders we're not talking about filing
petitions relative to Parenting plans or
relative to divorce or anything of that
nature again those are private actions
that's outside of the scope of the work
that the child support program does
um and our Bureau of child support legal
unit
consists currently of about 18 staff in
total whose sole responsibility is
ultimately to research those cases
prepare and file those legal petitions
and work with the courts to try to
establish those orders as effectively
and efficiently as we can
yes
may I just follow up on the timeline so
your timeline to seek an order from the
court is 90 days what about it when one
of the private action cases comes to the
bureau and says we would like this order
enforced what's the timeline from the
time
um a citizen would bring you their order
to the time that the child support is
actually collected
so thank you for the question
um when an order is received from our
program with an individual has applied
for child support services and they come
to us with a child support order we have
20 days to process the application and
then from there we have 90 days to
locate the individual who is responsible
for paying the child support and once we
have that locate information in place we
try to get that order up and running as
quickly as possible within at least
within a 30-day time frame we really
encourage we try to set the internal
parameter to try to get our orders up
and running within a couple of weeks
again all of those circumstances depend
upon whether or not we're able to have a
valid information on all the parties
that are involved so that we can ensure
that payments are being received and
distributed as quickly as possible
thank you
um so to speak just really briefly again
as I mentioned the two primary areas
that the Bureau of Child Support
Services works with the family division
Court was establishment I've spoken
about that the other half of uh the work
that we do with the child of the Family
Division court is through civil contempt
and or otherwise known as show cause
hearings perhaps for the enforcement of
child support orders of course the
Bureau of Child Support Services really
has an array of administrative
enforcement remedies and Court action
for us is always a last resort it is
really important that we ensure that
there is an actual that we we make every
effort to try to have to try to work
with a parent who is ordered to pay
child support to identify what if any
barriers they may have to be successful
in complying with their order and our
staff are equipped with the tools that
they need to be able to try to encourage
parents to comply on their own before we
take any type of enforcement or Court
action against them and we go through we
want to ensure that we've made every
effort possible
before we take um matters to court for
show cause hearings and our uh in 2016
the um the Federal Regulation titled the
flexibility efficiency and modernization
final rule was revised to ensure that
criteria for child support agencies
was
implemented so that
our child support programs could
determine and prepare and refer
appropriate cases to Courts for civil
contempt proceedings and within those
parameters the child support programs
are responsible to ensure that we have
actual and present information evidence
to support that an obligor or a person
that's responsible to pay child support
has the ability to comply with those
support orders and that's always
something that we're looking at and our
staff are looking at at the Forefront
so through our court administrative
order our child support staff are uh
that are employed by my Bureau are are
the Bureau of Child Support Services are
able to act in their official capacity
by bringing these cases forward and
presenting information to the courts for
consideration in these show cause
proceedings
so
um and these uh we you know our Bureau
of Child Support Services has worked uh
historically with the family division
Court to ensure that there's a uniform
enforcement process in place for these
types of civil uh contempt proceedings
brought forth through the court so
currently our program has 43 child
support officers who work with both
parents both for the establishment and
the child's uh enforcement as well as
the monitoring and compliance of child
support orders and
I think it's important to note that
through our Cooperative agreement with
the family division Court one that we've
had in place with a long-standing
history with the court and working with
the court that we continue to be able to
implement some ongoing activities for
regular liaison meetings with the family
division court and to ensure Statewide
Provisions are being met and to allow
for us to have some cross training
between our staff and the Family
Division Court staff you know child
support matters are really complex
families uh and and family circumstances
can be really complex so it's important
that we're
ensuring that our programs are both well
aware of ways that we can best support
those families that we're serving in the
variety of capacities
so
um in coming here today and giving the
opportunity to speak before the
committee there were a couple of things
that I wanted to bring to the
committee's attention just to
potentially share for considerations
that the committee may be able to take
in the um
in in relation to child support
the Bureau of Child Support Services and
the Department of Health and Human
Services here in New Hampshire is
required every four years by Statute to
facilitate a quadrennial review report
for our child support guidelines our
most recent the most recent report was
completed in December of 2022 and the
committee may want to consider taking a
look at that report if they if the
committee has not already to consider
the recommendations within that report
and how that might impact the work that
you're doing here there is some current
data in there from the work that our
program does as well as the Family
Division Court does with the child
support related matters and how that may
impact the child support guidelines
moving forward
and two other areas of notation are just
I just interrupted with that in that
report which will be
um made available to us uh
are there particular recommendations
uh to which you would like to draw our
attention
thank you for the question
representative I again I think that all
of the considerations should be take I
think all the recommendations should be
considered
um I think that there has been over the
last uh several quadrennial reviews
there's been
um some information made available to
our representatives in consideration for
what the legislature feels are the most
appropriate fair and Equitable changes
for our citizens and our job is to get
you the information from in that report
to help make to help consider what those
positions and considerations might be
you know the bureau really looks at is
here to provide that resource to you
but not really
um
uh
wouldn't want to necessarily include or
exclude any one of the potential
recommendations so I hear very clearly
what you're saying and I certainly share
um all of our beliefs that in this world
everything is equal but some are more
equal than others and if we cannot
get some helpful guidelines from those
people who are best situated to advise
us then that makes it much more
difficult for the legislature to do the
responsible things so I don't want to
pressure you and if you don't want to
answer I understand that you're under no
obligation but if you can identify some
that are more equal than others I do
think it might be helpful to us
representative law thank you madam chair
um with those recommendations are there
common denominators are they best suited
for payer payee
the bureau
or the court system Family Division do
you know or are they all over
so there were thank you representative
long and representative Smith for that
um there were ultimately 10
recommendations that were made by our
economists
that were that had completed the review
and they are partial in that
um basically they made recommendations
to update the guidelines percentages set
in statute and this is just the high
level recommendations from the executive
summary the report is available publicly
out on our department website for anyone
to view and certainly we could get that
to the committee if the committee
doesn't already have that information
but again it was to basically update the
guidelines percentages set in statute as
I have it right in front of me revise
the statutory Provisions covering the
preparation of the schedule and annual
update to make the schedule simpler to
understand replace
income deductions for work related child
care and so on and so forth so there are
I I won't take the time to read all of
them here but there were a variety of
recommendations that were made for both
parties thank you thank you
um
I think too that um to for consideration
of the committee of course naturally
there are always opportunities I think
that the department and the Family
Division Court could possibly uh enhance
informational resources to families to
help them navigate some of the complex
areas that we deal with in relation to
child support so certainly the Bureau of
Child Support Services
and the Family Division must meet those
increasing needs of families and for
their convenience of easy access to
services and if the committee has any
through your research and Gathering of
information
maybe there's some considerations there
where the bureau and the Family Division
can be more uh can enhance some of those
resources to our families to help them
navigate these circumstances
and of course I think it goes without
saying and I think you've heard this
already from several others who have
come before you at this committee is
that you know staff resources are always
something that could benefit both uh our
program as well as
um The Family Division I anticipate you
know we both strive to provide optimal
services and optimal Service delivery to
the families that we serve and we really
make every effort to try to meet those
time frames and work within the limited
resources that we have provided so you
know I our program really works to try
to ensure that we can be as efficient
and effective as we can for the families
that have applied for our services so
that we can ensure that families get the
income that they have been ordered to
receive and that we can help families
reduce those barriers so that they can
continue to support their children
um so um you know really in closing
the court is really a key stakeholder in
meeting the mission of the Bureau of
Child Support Services
and to really encourage and generate the
responsible parenting
um that um and self-sufficiency and
child well-being so we really depend the
Bureau of Child Support Services really
depends on having a strong collaborative
working relationship with the court to
which we have had for many decades now
and we continue to Foster that
relationship with the court and we're
really grateful for the opportunity to
have be able to work with the court in
the capacity that we do
thank you very much for your testimony
um Mr Hayes do you have anything you
want to add at this point
no thank you
um director deckatowski did a good job
okay nothing further to add to that
thank you um yes representative mcmack
thank you madam chair and um Mr kotowski
in the interest of Cooperative
collaboration to achieve consensus
do you uh in in your statement I'm
saying you work with the family court
in the last
let's say every four years I'll say last
three reports
have any of your recommendations not
yours but the um child support
guardianship guidelines been updated
reviewed or Changed by the legislature
I'd have to take a look at thank you for
the question representative and I have
to take a look at the statute and I'm a
statute book in front of me but I
believe the last significant changes to
the Child Support guideline statute was
in 2013.
um
so it's it's been a little while since
there's been a big overhaul in the
guidelines
follow-up if I may
uh but just in that today one other
question for you both
with that being said is uh we're here
because of the expression implied
conflicts of performance at the family
court level and those who have stand
before them the families
did the changes that these latest ones
um and that you indicated
give us 10 10 proposals made
of any of those
dealing with the
interactions of families petitioning
before the court to improve their ex
their results
thank you representative
I think if you um in in reviewing the
child support guidelines review report
that was submitted and looking at the
recommendations there are certainly
um
information
that is stated in the report that
suggests that parenting time and and
shared parenting time and deviations
from the child support guidelines if you
look at the deviation rates
um and the data that supports that in
the guidelines report which I don't have
that data in front of me and I would
want the committee to defer to the
report exactly and not take what I say
by wrote here but that there's a
significant amount of deviations from
the existing guidelines and that those
are the types of circumstances within
the review report that should be taken a
look at but as I stated before you know
again our role at the Bureau of Child
Support is to provide the committee with
a holistic approach excuse me a holistic
report of of current and relevant data
in the guidelines review report working
with our economists to provide the
legislative legislature with the
information to try to make what the best
decision is here for New Hampshire and
and we certainly
are available as a resource but and
willing to
um
happy to answer any questions about the
Bureau of Child Support Services and our
experience with that certainly the
report speaks to the data that we were
able to provide on behalf of the cases
and the families that we serve and the
circumstances that we see as well so it
gives you the um the balance between
both private action cases that we see
through the Family Division court and
the cases to which the Bureau of Child
Support Services
handles directly yeah follow up again
thank you madam chair uh just a word
flat clarification before my next
question did you say holistic or
ballistic holistic
just one of you come on to these things
just other not kidding I thought you
said ballistic this
um
on one of your comments where you that
you stated and appreciate your your
guidance here today is the um is working
whether the parent has the ability to
comply to the court order but came to my
mind then uh is do you represent both
parties and you become ultimately a
mediator before the court and is that
um oh do both
both sides of of the issue have access
to your services thank you
representative I I greatly appreciate
that question the answer is yes we are a
neutral third party
our job is to help both parents succeed
in the well-being and the success and
the compliance of their child support
orders yes we have an applicant our
applicant is can be either parent either
the one responsible to provide the
support or the one to receive the report
anyone is allowed to anyone is available
to apply for our services but the role
of our program is to be neutral is to
provide service to both
um both parents for the success and the
well-being of their children yeah thank
you thank you thank you madam chair
thank you
representative Macbeth thank you and
thank you for taking my question
um you had testified earlier that it
seems like there's two ways um the
people apply for your services either
the private action route or the the name
of what's the other route
so thank you for the question and the
opportunity for me to clarify
um because it seems like perhaps I
didn't do that well enough
um so every individual who of every
person that we serve every family that
we serve has to apply for our services
even if they come to us with an existing
order or they don't have an existing
child support order and they would like
us to establish one
so regardless uh so we help families we
have a lot of families that we help
um who who don't have parenting plans
who don't you know who have and again
ultimately the child support programs
Services a majority of families who are
single parent families who they've never
been married or not going through a
divorce but we do have another portion
you know we have a portion of our
families that we serve that do come with
us with existing orders already
so everyone must apply they either come
with us with an order or they don't have
an order and we work to establish one
for them
so actually so in the case of someone
that doesn't have an order and I think
that goes back to the recommendation
about the deviations so then it's the
bureau themselves that are bringing
forth and suggesting perhaps the
criteria for deviation and whether or
not it might apply to that case
uh representative thank you for the
question
um no actually so the court is the only
one that can make the determination as
to whether a deviation the bureau's
responsibility would be to gather the
information of the applicant and gather
the information of the other individual
and the parents in the case we would
then do our best to try to
utilize the existing child support
guidelines and the formulas to establish
an order based on that income from both
parties in circumstances where they
can't come to an agreement where there
may be circumstances
where they wish to agree to a different
amount or other factors may come into
play our job is to bring that
information to the court and the court
would assist in making a decision
if I could follow up just one more time
um
so
the divisions officers are just trying
to get an agreement they wouldn't be are
they is there an affirmative
um responsibility for them to inform the
individuals they could go to the court
and perhaps get a different order
absolutely that is part we we give our
families every opportunity we explain to
them every circumstance that is
available to us we we lay out how the
process will work we try to do our best
to facilitate with families if they're
willing to come into our office to come
to an agreement if they can't then are
we will explain to them the court
process and how we will help to file
that petition on their behalf with the
court and that's sorry thank you I have
one I just is this one short may may I
follow up Mr chair
um who pays for this is there a payment
for the services so when someone applies
is there a payment
so our our services there we have an
application uh fee that is a very small
fee only that is for folks who apply for
our services
it's a 35 application fee if you are and
I don't
um
I'll have to get you the specifics
although if I could look at my director
thank you so it's a thank you it's a 35
annual fee for non-public assistance
recipients
thank you very much thank you
if I may add onto that um with respect
to filing petitions on behalf of the
parties um
as director takatowski pointed out
um
uh
our attorneys don't represent any of the
parties represent the state our client
is the Bureau where as she's pointed out
our purpose is to help get the parties
before the court so that decision on
child support can be made we file the
petitions and we affect service on the
other party so those are fees that they
would uh of a filing party would
normally have to pay that they don't
have to pay so I just wanted to make
sure the committee knew that as well
thank you
thank you madam chair that the um I I
heard you say you're responsible for
both child and medical support the
medical kind of flew me a little bit I
didn't quite realize that is the medical
also included in title 4D
or is it just child support
do you want to do you want to answer
that
uh medical sport is in would be in title
40 as well and uh if we would enforce
medical sport if there was a separate or
there's a couple different ways it comes
up uh medical support can also can be uh
in a in a support order let's say the
party's split medical costs on internal
medical costs 50 50 which is typically
what happens uh if someone incurred
let's say a thousand two thousand
dollars in medical costs and the other
party
you know wasn't making payments on their
own and they had to go to court the
court would adjudicate that arrange and
that would be a special medical support
or rearing that would be separate from
child support and that that's some type
that's one type of a rear edge that the
hero couldn't enforce
that's one way it comes up and then the
other way it comes up is with medical
or health insurance on the bureau
has enforcement remedies it can use to
compel compliance with a court order
with respect to obtaining health
insurance for a child
okay very good thank you
no
if you could help clarify something for
me you talked about the deadlines you
have a timeline 30 days 90 days whatever
um do you keep track in any way of
um
however you measure it let's just say
the percentage of cases which uh fall
within the uh
established timelines and those that do
not
thank you for the question yes we do
representative and we can certainly get
you and the committee those percentages
if that's something you're interested in
thank you very much can you tell me
um
is do you ever find yourself in a
situation where there is a conflict
between the Federal
requirements and state law
not that I can speak to no
that's a relief
thank you are there any other questions
I thank you very much for the time that
you've given to us
um we're trying to do the right thing
and we need the input from you I do
understand that the report you
referenced earlier is
um working its way through
um
to get to all members of the committee
and so we will benefit from that is
there anything else that you could say
um
to help us
reach our goal which is making sure that
we're doing everything we can to ensure
that the family court is
living up to its obligations to meet the
needs of the people of the state
um
you've already mentioned one that
applies to you when we know it applies
to the courts and that's the
availability of resources and so that we
understand but is there anything else
that you might want to just in closing
share with us
thank you representative
um no I don't have anything additional
to say in closing we just want to thank
the committee for the work that you're
doing
um thank you again for the opportunity
uh for us to come here to present on
behalf of the Bureau of child support
and the Department of Health and Human
Services and certainly we are available
to any and all of you as a resource
should any other information or
questions arise throughout your
information gathering process please
don't hesitate thank you
thank you very much for taking the time
thank you
um
representative bigford
I I see a card from you do you want to
speak with reference to
um the child support
presentation that's just been made
oh is that what you would like to speak
to today then I would like to recognize
you following this and then we'll move
on to the next topic
excuse me
well yes we have Ned Gordon but if what
you want to speak about is is this
all right
fine then I think that we'd like to hear
from you now
no no no I'm I'm taking the prerogative
of the the chair to say that um we get
confused easily here and we want to make
sure that we keep
like topics together
no I assume you don't need a quorum to
we do not need a quorum we are not
voting as you know representative
Bickford that's the only time we need a
quorum okay good and you also know that
this is being recorded I do and it's and
it's being seen live and at least one of
our absentees is home with the dreaded
covid and probably watching oh I do
watch these I've only missed the last
one so far and uh I can hear them very
well on the uh
monitor my computer monitor
anyway what I wanted to speak to is that
the problem with child support is is not
to me it's not the courts and it's not
the
Department of Child Support Services the
problem is the guidelines themselves
now I was on the uh commission to study
child support in 2004.
and I learned a tremendous amount at
that time I was the vice chair of that
committee
but I'd like to go back and speak to
some of the background
uh which I've learned a lot from the
these quarterly
um some of those that are lawyers uh the
family law quarterly
I used to subscribe to and they're
incredible information in them
anyway
um
the problem is legislative negligence
that's what the real problem is here
um but historically it was in 1985
Lenore Weitzman wrote a book titled the
divorce Revolution
they claimed women and children averaged
a 73 percent drop in standard of living
after divorce while fathers increase 42
percent
it turned out to be completely false
but
it ignited a child support Revolution at
the federal level and Congress
strengthened the guidelines requirement
through the Family Support Act of 1988
Section 102 of the ACT requires states
to provide by October 13
1989 that in any judicial or
administrative support proceeding there
shall be a rebuttable presumption that
the guideline amount is correct
amount of support to be awarded
since then a lot has changed we have
many more parents that both parents are
the uh taking care of their children
and we changed the law in New Hampshire
and get rid of the term visitation so we
now have two parents well we used to
have just one though the guidelines are
created for
to be one parent and one visitor that
has parental responsibility particularly
financial responsibility
and that creates a real problem to try
to adjust and it's even bigger problem
when you try to factor in lifestyle
rather than just support levels
the following is from the review of the
New Hampshire child support guidelines
of December 31 of
2022. it's I believe 200 pages of it
it's very good well done
I don't know what they paid for it I
happen to have all of the reviews done
the four-year studies required by the
federal government so if anybody's
interested in historical information I'd
be happy to share that
um I had research here get them uh for
me and Bickford recently got them for me
but I already have several here
and and in those
to start with the the most recent one
New Hampshire uses the income shares
model which entitles the same level of
expenditures the child would have
received had the parents lived together
as I pointed out that's problem number
one
the New Hampshire guideline system is
based on lifestyle not the actual
support needs of the child however
support needs can be used as a deviation
for low-income parents you'll see that
on page 107.
the analysis of the case File data found
a deviation rate of 61 percent among
divorce and
and uh parenting petitions
New Hampshire deviation rate is much
higher than that of other states I'm
reading this verbatim right from the
study
over half the deviations were known to
be due
to the parenting or caused by the
parenting schedule see page II
now in comparison the state does foster
care or the Social Security System phase
for the decisive apparent this
there's one fee is for the support not
for a lifestyle
so I just want to keep pointing that out
that's where we skewed
or the federal government forced us a
skew there
um does the government really have a
right to demand a parent exchange from
one parent to the other what would be
discretionary and not needed for the
support of children in a marriage when
we stop the courts from ordering College
expenses
in 2004 it was because married parents
are not required to do so therefore
neither should divorced separated or
widowed parents
in other words we treat them as a
we discriminate against divorced parents
is what we do
recommendation number six of the 22
review adopt a time-sharing adjustment
recognition number seven from the family
law task force
of 2004 Nina Gardner was our executive
director uh
cheered it rather
um this is the best thing we ever did
you got time we sat together we had
people from a court
um the Departments there and we came up
with several recommendations we got
quite a bit of it uh passed but one
thing didn't and that is from uh on page
9 and 12 States amend child support
statutes to deal with shared or split
residence Arrangements
that's 2004 that's almost 20 years now
recommendation number three from the
child support guidelines review of 2018.
that was the one before this one
um address shared parenting they even
sent us
an addendum in 2019 to use just for
shared parenting
from Dartmouth College uh Kristen Smith
to be exased
uh recommendation number three from the
2009 New Hampshire child support
guidelines review we recommend New
Hampshire adopt the Shared Parenting
adjustment currently used by Vermont
this involves multiplying the basic
order by 1.5 to account for the
additional fixed costs associated with
raising a child in two homes and
subtracting an amount directly
proportional to the fraction of time an
obligor spends with a child
as measured in overnights
adopt a simple cross calculation method
for setting Awards in cases of exactly
equal shared parenting time or split
custody
um
that was that was done by uh the
university the extension service did our
review that time Dr Kalinowski and Dr uh
I can't remember first name Smith
from Durham
you just made that up he did The
Bullying uh statutes too
um
commissioned to study child support and
related child custody issues on December
1st of 2004 guidelines are skewed by
Department of Agriculture reports of
expenditures on children and by families
due to the way they calculate housing
and transportation
in that case if someone has one child
then half the cost of the automobile
expenses and and payments
is retributed to a child and it's the
same thing with housing all of a sudden
if you have a house and you have one
child half the cost of the house so that
really skews things that's on page 32.
excuse me alimony moved Beyond support
to permitting the more dependent spouse
to become financially independent or to
have the same standard of living as
during the marriage and child support
has also moved Beyond to become child
alimony
keep in mind one parent must pay the
other for a standard of living or go to
jail
but the other parent
is under no obligation to provide that
standard of living to the child
that's what happens when you create a
standard living thing
um
I just want to point out it
back
around 2004 I can remember exactly when
one or 2002 probably when I was here
serious mistakes can happen
I I was on the child and family law
committee at that time and I was trying
to understand the child support because
the statute said it was income shias
which is a model federal government told
us to we could use
but the guidelines were written around
percent of obligora
and I can remember asking Joan Williams
I said I don't get it your father's wow
I guess it's a kind of a hybrid thing
well it was a serious mistake and if you
go to the poor these things here they
say
like guidelines are not
what the statute said
yeah that was a big whoops
uh on iPad
um
one of the things I want to point out
further is there's been a few
uh Supreme Court decisions it was
Anderson and there was Silva most
recently this says
these things need to be decided by the
legislature they're not going to
continue to keep making deviations
when there's just a sad parenting issue
going on that the legislature needs to
deal with it our problem has not been
the child and family law committee so
much as it has been the Senate
care
are you nearing the end am I what are
you nearing the end of your presentation
yes I am good I'm sorry to hear you say
that
representative Bickford you and I go
back to 19 the election of 1996 so I am
well conditioned to listen to your every
word
that's right
that's right we started in a Judiciary
and we sat beside each other
and we were good classmates
and you're more long-winded than I am
representing him with that I will
conclude my
um
testimony
thank you very much and do you have
um written a copy of that testimony
um that you could share with us that
would be very good one without notes
because you're so succinct
representative
thank you madam chairwoman and thank you
representative Bickford for taking my
question I was wondering if you have a
copy of actually the
study or report that you did in 2004
because I do see that the guidelines
were changed in 2005 and I think they
corrected kind of much of what you said
and then for some reason in 2013 this
statue was modified to say that there
couldn't be a deviation for shared split
parenting time and that the courts
didn't necessarily comply with it until
the Silva V Silva case
um was decided in 2018 and when that
Supreme Court decision was decided the
judges then
stopped deviating because like you know
it was confirmed that the statue says
that you can't so I'm wondering if
we could look at some of those
recommendations that you had because I'm
wondering if whom changed it in 2013
wasn't aware of these recommendations
that you had already kind of looked into
the change that was made I think in 20
2013 was probably the guidelines
themselves to represent income shares no
no the change in 2013 is the is the
current change which states that you
can't make a deviation solely based on
shared slash split parenting time and it
wasn't necessarily as well enforced
until it was affirmed in the syllabi
Silva Supreme Court case somebody who
frequently comes in to our committee
Vivian Gerard when that was decided in
2018 that's when
it was kind of effort but it was in 2013
that that was changed the the RSA was
changed to state that
the guidelines couldn't be changed just
because of split or shared parenting
time previously in 20 2005. let's just
say the guidelines can't be changed or
does it say that you that's the order
the support can't be
uh
necessarily changed because of only
having a um
um
she had parenting time
it the statue the statute States
is
not necessarily the they don't have to
change the court does not have to make a
change
as I recall
yeah so
yeah that's right it says in considering
that the parenting schedule that can't
be like the sole reason for why that
they're making a deviation
you're right
it can't be the soul
yeah
yeah we didn't want to uh
actually we were expecting the course
they have deviation on these things but
we never really came up with a good set
of guidelines and yet year you know
study after study says you got to do it
we're only one out of
I think there's only nine states left
that hasn't done it
uh it this is a legislative action I'm
sorry I
when I thought 13 it was actually before
that when I
I'm going off in a little different
direction when I discovered that we were
using percent of income uh we we did
change it uh to income shares the
guidelines
um to do that I had Ed Morin who was the
chairman of the committee file it rather
than in my name and it might look a
little inflammatory
and uh what we did was in in that case
was copied Vermont
uh I just thought I'd throw that in
but um
this do you understand
on your question though about
so I was just asking if we could see the
report that you had had I know you
referenced it the 2004 report because I
think it you know I said it was a 2004
report well you had referenced it in
your testimony that you guys had done
this this study and it was subsequently
changed to to say that equal or
approximately equal parenting
responsibilities shall not eliminate the
need for child support or modification
of the guidelines and I just wanted to
see your report because I think it was
in contradiction to this I just wanted
to be able to see the report
um perhaps excuse me perhaps
representative you could I have all the
reports that's terrific and let's um I
know you'd want to hear that so well I'm
not surprised and if if I'm not sure
which report it's in right now well
let's at this point let's just thank you
for your very very helpful testimony and
you and the clerk can uh of the
committee can
establish exactly what information she
would like from your
um extensive collection okay
yes thank you very much for appearing
before I also have this on digital too
the family law task force uh
terrific I really appreciate that thank
you very much and at this point uh just
a little late but not terribly late
um I would like to represent uh to
recognize
um Ned Gordon without title just Ned
Gordon
see you again
and Ned Gordon's colleague yes
good morning I hope we haven't kept you
waiting too long you have not and thank
you madam chair members of the committee
nice to see you all again
my name is Ned Gordon and uh I had the
pleasure of serving as a circuit court
judge
uh having been appointed in 2005 and
volunteering in 2006 to serve in the
Family Division the newly created Family
Division under the Circuit Court
the
uh and served there for 12 years until
my retirement and uh 12 years later so
for 12 years I did rule on Family
Division cases and
heard Family Division cases so I'm here
today to talk about neutral case
evaluation which is what I'm doing now
post retirement
and the court has uh long recognized
that
the old standard trial procedure isn't
necessarily the best way to resolve
cases
that are based on familial relationships
and are highly emotional and so it has
developed alternative dispute resolution
processes one of which is nce neutral
case evaluation but more frequently used
is mediation and I brought along with me
today Margaret Wang who is the
coordinator for the circuit court for
alternative dispute resolution and so
I'm going to talk a little bit about
neutral case evaluation but I thought
you might want to hear from her as well
with regard to the mediation if we have
time to do that today
so neutral case evaluation
is an opportunity for particularly cases
than dispute that are and going to end
up going to a trial or a final hearing
and they are generally post-discovery
after people have exchanged information
and they've been scheduled for trial or
final hearing and the parties agree and
to a neutral case evaluation going in
front of a retired jurist a someone who
has been deciding cases in the past to
attempt to resolve their case
and
it's a period of time generally
scheduled for three hours period of time
where that retired judge such as myself
will hear from the parties
maybe separate the parties hear from
them individually
and then try to give them an idea of how
a judge would decide their case
and
the question is can you can you do that
and one of the
I'll tell you two things about Judges
and this is what I would tell everybody
about Judges first of all judges are not
problem solvers
judges are decision makers
I think that's one of the issues that
you probably should be addressing in
your committee and that is people come
to the family division with the
expectation that their problem is going
to be solved where basically what judges
do is decide decisions and they decide
decisions pretty mechanically
just like you've just heard about child
support
you have created laws that pretty much
establish how cases are going to be
decided so you establish a law with
regard to child support you a law regard
to how you apply alimony you have laws
with regard to property division you
have all these laws that you've
established there's also case law which
I just have to follow
and there are court rules that the
judges have to follow and there are best
practices there are protocols that
judges follow so by the time you do that
judging a case is a pretty mechanical
exercise
and so I think you can predict in many
cases how a case is going to be decided
the second thing you need to know about
Judges
is that they're human
and
they put you they put a robe on you as a
judge and they would give you the idea
that you're really smart and that you're
infallible but the fact is that judges
are not infallible they're just as human
as anybody else and they do make
mistakes
but
judges uh
there's a long process for correcting
those mistakes in many cases which is
the appeal process and uh
so
with regard to the the making decisions
it's a mechanical process and somewhat
predictable but because judges are human
uh it's not as predictable that elements
are predictable so every time you go in
front of a judge you sort of take your
chances there are different judges some
judges are very formal some judges are
very friendly some judges
are detail-oriented analytical other
judges are very just expressive and so
you you take your chances and that's
what are you constantly hear from other
attorneys is you know it depends on who
I'm going to get from my judge today so
long and short so what happens at the
nce is you sit down with the parties you
hear what their interests are
and you do your very best to to
determine how they would end up better
off because the fact is that if you
simply go through the process
mechanically neither party may end up in
the best situation they could be and by
a judge sitting down with them saying
this is how I think your case will be
decided now what's important to you
each party can then emphasize what they
would like to see happen
a for example is uh recently with a
neutral case evaluation
husband's biggest concern was saving his
retirement plan he did not want to give
up his retirement plan
but
the wise biggest concern was she wanted
to have a steady income
so the long and the short is when if you
had just gone to a judge and the judge
decided that mechanically he would have
divided that retirement plan in half
okay and probably given alimony just
according to statute
but then at the end at the neutral case
evaluation
hearing from the parties what we could
do is say okay what we're going to do is
we're going to escalate the alimony
because that's really what the wife
wants is she needed to have a steady
income and he wanted to preserve so he
could preserve his retirement and they
the two parties end up better off than
they would have if they had just gone to
trial and gone before a judge
and that's a neutral case evaluation as
the idea that people can resolve their
case in a manner which both parties end
up or benefit from
and it works very well right now at
least as far as I'm concerned 50 percent
of the time we resolve the case we
settle the cases before they go to trial
it goes to
uh it and that saves the court time
saves the court money
in terms of expense
and you end up with a better result for
everybody for the court system
for the state and for the parties
I can talk add Margaret explain a little
bit about mediation as well and how
we're using the media if
before before we get to that
representative Kota
thank you madam chairwoman and thank you
for taking my question on uh
I wanted to ask so you said 50 of the
time you're able to resolve the cases I
was wondering
is this neutral case evaluation being
offered in all of the course just
certain ones or
what's the current status with it is it
a you know a pilot program where it's
only being offered in certain courts
yeah yeah
so it's offered Statewide
um currently all of our nces are
occurring in Concord probate
um
it has been a robust service and it was
a more robust service prior to the
pandemic where we both had sitting and
retired judges doing neutral case
evaluations
um after the pandemic with the backlog
of cases all of our judicial resources
have been used to hear cases so as a
result the ADR office has been using
retired judges to do neutral case
evaluations
um as such there are fewer neutral case
evaluations than was back in 2019 but
there are still I think around like
175 this year that are available should
people wish to do them
is there a fee involved in
participating in this program
so for neutral case evaluation there is
not a fee
thank you for taking my question
um so of the 175 cases that are
available is the demand greater than
that
we have attorneys have asked us
um to increase the neutral case
evaluation program
thank you
good morning members of the committee
and uh Madam chair Smith
my name is Margaret Huang and I am the
alternative dispute resolution
coordinator for the New Hampshire
judicial branch
in this position I oversee 16 court
connected alternative dispute resolution
or ADR programs across the Supreme
Superior and circuit courts
there are about 4 600 ADR sessions that
occur per year across these Court
connected programs we have two court
connected ADR programs that are
available in divorce parenting cases
mediation and neutral case evaluation
thank you to judge Gordon for inviting
me to talk about mediation
so judge Gordon gave you a description
of what neutral case evaluation looks
like from the perspective of a judge or
an evaluator and I will give you an
overview of our mediation program from
the perspective of a program manager of
course if you have any nce questions
that are program related as well please
feel free to ask me or to ask me to talk
more about the nce program I would be
happy to
okay so what is mediation
mediation is an informal process in
which the parties meet with a certified
family mediator to work out decisions
relating to Parenting and divorce
mediation provides parents with a
collaborative environment in which to
make these decisions and as such
mediation gives parents an opportunity
to resolve matters in a way that
addresses the concerns and interests of
both the parents and the child or
children
mediation is generally governed by three
major principles self-determination
impartiality and confidentiality
self-determination is the concept that
any decisions that the parties come to
should be voluntary and uncoerced the
mediator does not have any authority to
force the parties to come to a certain
resolution or any resolution
the role of the mediator is to work with
parties to explore what they care about
what their options are for meeting their
needs how these options may impact their
situation and to find areas of agreement
second is impartiality mediators are
neutral which means that they are not
partial towards or prejudiced against
any party and they should not have a
stake in the outcome and lastly
confidentiality because mediation is
confidential anything that is said or
written during mediation cannot be
shared with the judge hearing the case
or used in any further Court proceedings
mediations are confidential for the same
reasons that settlement negotiations are
confidential and inadmissible we want
people to be as open as they can be
should to try to reach resolution
without the fear that what they're going
to say is going to be used against them
should the case go back to court
for cases with children all parties are
referred to mediation unless there's a
statutory reason not to or if a
different avenue such as a hearing or a
case manager conference is more
appropriate for cases without children
parties are offered mediation at their
first court hearing and parties can
choose how they want the mediation to
occur whether it's over Zoom or in
person at the courthouse this way
parties choose the process that works
best for them whether it's mediating in
person because they may be uncomfortable
with technology or mediating over video
because they may have issues with
Transportation or be less able to take
time off work
at the date and time of mediation
mediation starts with the mediator
explaining the process and the ground
rules for participation
the mediator then leads parties through
a discussion around topics such as
property division time with children
decision making and transportation
if the parties come to an agreement on a
topic the mediator will keep track of
the agreements that are reached again
mediation is a voluntary process so the
parties may come to an agreement on all
of the issues some of the issues or not
agree
after the mediation session if the case
settles either the parties or the
mediator will submit the required
documents to the court
if the case does not settle parties can
either agree to ongoing mediation or
return the case back to court
as judge Gordon said judges are decision
makers
in mediation parents can be problem
solvers
at a minimum mediation provides a
facilitative collaborative space for
parties to negotiate with each other and
work out solutions to problems that may
have arisen
it is a process that has a lower barrier
to entry to court for example you don't
need to know the rules of evidence in
order to participate effectively
and critically it allows for legally
irrelevant interests to be important
judges are concerned with the facts that
will assist them in making a decision
and that may not be what is most
important to the parties
in mediation parties are able to talk
about what is most important to them
even if it's not relevant in regards to
the law
at its best mediation strives to Foster
understanding help people feel heard and
assist people with generating creative
and tailored Solutions
every family is different and so every
mediation and every mediated agreement
will be different
that being said mediation is not
appropriate for every case
RSA 461a7 and RSA 45815c list out some
circumstances in which the court may
choose not to order mediation
they include a showing of undue hardship
an agreement between the parties for
different ADR procedures
an allegation of abuser neglect a
finding of alcoholism or drug abuse an
allegation of serious psychological or
emotional abuse
and both statutes state that the court
shall not order mediation if there is a
finding of domestic violence as defined
in RSA 173 B1 unless all parties agree
to mediation
oh sorry
um I will try to finish up quickly
um in 2021
3228 mediation sessions were held
about 38 percent were ongoing so they
needed an additional mediation session
28 did not settle seven percent
partially settled and 22 percent fully
settled that being said the outcome of a
mediation is not necessarily an
indicator for whether it's successful
a settled mediation can save parties
time
and expense of going on with the court
process and can reduce the court the
workload of a court but a partially
settled mediation also saves the court
time and can reduce say a two-day trial
to a one-day trial and can help the
parties figure out what they actually
disagree about or what they need more
information on
going mediation means that there are
additional topics that need a longer
discussion and the parties are willing
to come back to the table to have that
discussion with each other or that they
need to come to a temporary agreement
that they will try out and then go back
to mediation to tweak
and a mediation that does not settle can
clarify for parties the need to go to
court the need for Discovery to be
completed that mediation is not the
right Avenue for them or that they have
simply exercised their right to
self-determination
mediation is successful if it provides
parties with a quality process
of the 129 feedback responses we've
received from parties going through
divorce parenting mediation
97.7 percent of people felt like the
mediator explained the process answered
all of their questions were treated
fairly and with respect
and lastly my last point is that 90.7 of
people who responded said they would use
mediation again if they needed to thank
you
thank you uh very much for that of the
129 responses what does that represent
in terms of the total number of
mediation so that were conducted
probably a fairly minimal percentage
however all parties are offered the
opportunity to provide their feedback at
the end of mediation so these are just
the ones that we've received thank you I
I understand that and I am quite taken
by your
enthusiastic support of this effort but
it helps us if we can
really
um
if we have just the facts ma'am and 129
responses is fine but one must wonder if
the people who responded are the very
people who are happiest
with the process and the rest aren't so
when I ask you that question it's not in
any challenging or hostile way it's just
to better evaluate and related to that
what is the cost of mediation
mediation is currently 300 per case
which is a hundred and fifty dollars per
party however effective July 1st um with
an amendment that was passed by the
Supreme Court mediation will increase to
450 dollars per case or 225 dollars per
party the increase is a result of the
fact that the mediation fee has not
increased for the past 20 years and
um to make it commensurate with what the
gal and uh defense attorney increase has
been earlier this year thank you
representative long
thank you madam chair uh thank you this
is uh very helpful
um
in mediation are are they had had uh uh
Mr Gordon stated
um the judges will give them an
anticipation of what he believes the
result will be uh in mediation is that
also the case
it's it's not that's a great question no
it's not so
um nce has that added component of
providing an evaluation but the
mediation does not
okay and uh fall off I may the uh data
is important
is there data kept on what how many
hours possibly were saved
uh with a potential mediation is is that
data kept somewhere court hours ever
saved I'm not sure but I could see if we
have that today all right thank you
thank you yes representative McBeth
thank you
um thank you for taking my question it's
great to see you um representative
Gordon
um how do we the neutral case
evaluations you say it's dropped the the
amount we're able to offer
um what would be what's needed to bring
that up to pre-covered levels or even to
address all the cases now
that that might require it I think you
said that there were
146 or seven and I think we heard
previous testimony that they're 30 000
cases filed each year in New Hampshire
family court so how could we maybe make
those numbers meet better
I think that in order to expand the
program we would need additional staff
in order to process that paperwork and
to really implement it day to day on the
ground you know getting files to the
right places for example
processing forms Etc I also think that
we would need more judicial resources
like I had said all of our judges are
currently sitting and so having more
resources would mean that they would
have more space to be able to engage in
alternative dispute resolution
thank you
I think I'm Madam chair our attorneys
present at nces or mediation both
yes so attorneys always have the
opportunity to participate in both okay
thank you
and and that's been and with regard to
mediation you have you see many
non-represented parties in the mediation
but in the nces it's rare to see a
non-represented party usually attorneys
because you're getting to the point
where you're going to trial
thank you
thank you madam chair and ma'am how do I
pronounce your last name
it's Huang Wang that's like I heard the
alternative I want to make sure I had it
right
uh in previous testimony we had on May
16th
the uh comments were made I'm going for
my notes right now that the Rules of
Evidence
are not in play in Family Court
but you've just you referred in your
commentary
Rules of Evidence what's correct
I'm sorry if I misspoke it was an
example well it shows I'm actually
paying attention to it I'm good thank
you okay just a follow-up
um for his honor
uh with your 12-year experience
and haven't been the authority having
jurisdiction which is redundant
what is not happening in Family Court
since you left that brings us to this
tribunal if you will on improving what
takes place for our citizens who come
before the court
two minutes that's a big question for
two minutes I can uh I can tell you uh
uh a few thoughts
um
one is uh
it gets to the issue of the court is not
a problem solver the court is a decision
maker I think many people come to court
with the expectation that their problem
is going to be solved
so if I have a recent case where the 14
year old kid
parents married 20 years they have a kid
mom's got a new boyfriend they've
separated and this kid is just torn
apart has
just emotionally
traumatized over this divorce
and
is upset with Mom upset with dad doesn't
like Dad because she doesn't really have
a relationship with Dad dad hasn't been
much in her life and and they come to
court the parents seem to be coming to
court with the idea that the Court's
going to solve that problem for them
and the court isn't going to solve that
problem there are some problems the
court cannot solve and it can make an
effort to solve those problems it can
you know advocate for counseling it can
do certain things but there are certain
problems in Kansas but people have
expectations that the court is going to
do more
then the court can actually do in many
cases and unfortunately
the other the other issue is
uh these are these are huge emotional
issues that people are involved with and
I can tell you sitting on the guardian
at lighting board for example
um people come in and they believe they
believe 100 that their right with regard
to what their kid needs and and that's
great you know and a parent you want a
parent to be enthusiastic but there are
different points of view on what's in a
child's best interest and sometimes a
judge will have
a different view as to what's in a
child's best interest
a guardian Elida might have a different
view of what it was in the trial's best
interest
and in many cases that parent who's so
invested emotionally whatever else can't
see that there are different points of
view or people can have different ideas
of what's in the child's best interest
so they view that difference as bias
as opposed to a different point of view
or or or the fact that somebody has just
got it wrong
and that I think that's certainly one of
the issues that you have to deal with I
think there's another issue with regard
and uh you know the court system might
know let me even talk about this but
another issue is uh judges
we we had a system at one point in time
where we had marital Masters all of them
had practiced family law
and uh were hired because they were
family law practitioners and became
marital Masters
and knew the law practiced the law and
did what they wanted to do
now we're appointing judges
in many cases that have had no
experience at all in family law who have
been prosecutors defense attorneys
administrative judges contract reviewers
um and and putting a robe on them and
having sending them out to do family law
and I think that's uh I think that's an
issue that we should look at and it's
not that they might not be capable of
doing it but the question is do they
want to do it I know that there are some
judges that aren't really enthusiastic
about doing family law and it's probably
the hardest thing as a judge that you do
as a family law cases because
um
unless you have the nce or the mediation
and you work through these things
the reason that the trial system doesn't
work is because there are winners and
losers
and when you and that's that's the
that's the problem with the trial system
and that's why nce works that's why
mediation works even with the nces we we
settle 50 of the cases but the other
cases are well on their way to being
settled or resolved because what you've
done is if there are 10 issues in the
case you resolved eight of them in the
nce and they're just two left that need
to be addressed by a judge someplace
um so those are those are some of my my
thoughts if if you were gonna if you
were going to have a judge to be a
family if you were going to have if you
were going to hire somebody
uh for a job you would hire somebody who
was experienced and qualified
and it seems to me that we should have
judges if you were going to hire if you
wanted a judge to be a family court
judge and I think that was the intention
I you know I was one of the sponsors of
the original Family Division Bill and
it was
with the idea that one family one judge
and this was going to be a judge that
wanted to be a family court judge
and one follow-up Madam chair
thank you Joanna for that comment on
that being stated what was provided to
us under the this document that was
given to us
it states here the parties shall have
attended mediation prior to an nce does
that stipulate that that process is made
available to
um the parties coming before the court
system prior to an action being
initiated
that they know they haven't that
option
no option that that's the process
uh I'll have somebody else can answer
that
um so nce is typically offered at the
later stages of a case and so mediation
needs to have already occurred or the
case is inappropriate for mediation and
we also ask for Discovery to be complete
so that it's the best use of the judge's
time
um so
most cases will be given the option of
mediation at the very first stage right
first appearance first court appearance
um so we just ask that they have either
completed mediation or again it's not
appropriate before trying nce
okay just one point of clarification
Madam chair
if I may
uh that being said in in and also
writing down what the honor you know the
owner had stated what regarding bias
with that
set a stage of Express or implied bias
on fair treatment of either party when
mediation is taken off the table before
an opportunity
the opportunity that is provided
and then to go to an nce scenario
I think who makes that decision it's is
it the parties or is it the does it
start at the uh at the judge
with the case
sorry
um so mediation is determined to be uh
inappropriate by Statute so RSA 461 A7
and RSA 45815c
um it would be a the judge who is
hearing the case would probably rule on
whether or not mediation is appropriate
or not
um that being said the person who does
the neutral case evaluation
um is not the judge hearing the case it
is a different judge who typically does
not have any knowledge of the case prior
to going through nce with the parties
okay thank you thank you madam chair if
I can just add in the nces there's
specifically an agreement first of all
the parties have to agree that they want
to do nce and second uh they sign an
agreement where
the the judge who does the nce cannot be
subpoenaed to any of the information
that came out of the NC it's completely
confidential
thank you madam chairwoman and thank you
honorable Gordon for taking my question
you have a lot of experience in all of
this so I'm wondering and you don't have
to answer this question but if you don't
mind sharing your opinion if you could
make any changes what three changes
would you potentially make that might
have what you think might be the biggest
you know most positively impactful
as a result of it
are you changes to what the Family
Division as a whole you mean the whole
process as a whole family Division and
and that you know as a whole yeah well
and and if I could
think about their two Avenues one is the
legislature is suggesting to the court
changes that the court could make and
the other is the legislature taking
direct action
yeah you may have 30 seconds to think
about it
I
uh you know one
they were there I don't know there's
there's a few things I I guess one one
is
um
I I think there are two things one is
making sure you have the the resources
that you need to get the job done
and right now I don't believe there are
adequate resources to do that
particularly with regard to Staffing
even more so I think than judging from
my opinion
that you're really the staffing issues
are critical
I've seen orders for that
have been ruled on and then not sent out
for two or three weeks later and that's
just not acceptable when you have
circumstances where you've got families
and dealing with children and and these
are critical issues to families and it
needs to happen and so they need the
resources and I think the other issue is
allocation
of resources I think uh you know the
whole concept between the Family
Division when we
created the original
pilot program in Rockingham County up in
Grafton County was you know that we were
going to make this
we're going to make the system better
and we were going to have one judge one
family
and
consistency between
consistency and rulings between the
families
um
and I
guess I would like to see that happened
and that the people who were doing the
cases are people who want to hear the
cases
uh that and who are qualified the most
qualified people to hear the cases as
well so
I have a couple of questions one of them
is incredibly naive
no I can't believe that
it's incredibly naive
is there any state in the United States
which does not use the judicial system
to resolve issues
um
that
end up in the family court
I'm not aware of any
that doesn't mean there aren't any I'm
just not aware of any
thank you
um
is there
any
reasonable way
that the process for
assigning judges to the family court
could differ
from the process of assigning judges to
other
functioning areas in the Circuit Court
um
I don't I don't know the
answer to that I
there was there was a time when
the
when I was first appointed I was
appointed as the presiding judge of the
Franklin District Court
so
and there were other judges who
were appointed in that way and they were
district court judges and
like me they were given the option of
hearing Family Division cases and many
of those judges decided
that they didn't want to hear Family
Division cases and so they didn't hear
Family Division cases
which
and so then you what you did with that
sort of narrowed down the pool so you
only had judges who wanted to hear
Family Division here cases hearing them
but now I think it appears everybody's
appointed with the understanding that
they will hear Family Division cases
um
so I I don't know the answer to that I
don't know
I think you'd have to answer have talked
to somebody
with some Authority
to get the answer to that question
well
with all due respect depends upon how
you define Authority
and in this case I'm asking a person who
in my mind has the authority to make
informed decisions and that's why I ask
you
you don't have to answer let me if if if
you uh you know basically judge
assignment is uh uh you know judges can
be assigned to different types of cases
so if you wanted to reassign judges to
specific types of cases you could do
that
it I think it
it cuts down somewhat on efficiency to
do that but you
become by doing specialization you cut
down maybe on some efficiency but at the
same time
uh maybe you
can end up with a better product too but
that's just my thought
do you see a problem of geography
in all this I mean some courts are going
to have many many cases
that are family court cases and some
courts I imagine have many fewer I mean
uh
and
that might mean that judges have to
be in the Circuit Court have to actually
have a circuit in the way they did in
the old days yeah
well they could
I think that is a matter of assignment
um
could I ask you to take off your neutral
case evaluation hat
um and put on the gal hack
when you appeared before us a number of
weeks ago you gave some very helpful
testimony
since then this committee has heard from
any number of people about a number of
issues and one of them has to do
with how in fact g-a-l
is working now first question in terms
of your role
are you involved
exclusively in what as a layperson I
would call the casa component
as compared with
the court
component I said on the I said as a
board member on the guardian of Litem
board a public member
appointed to serve on the guardian
lighting board
and
as such
I we
all guarding that items are subject to
the guardian that light and board that
includes private Guardian ad items and
Casa Guardian items there is a
uh there are there is
a mou with regard to Casa in the manner
in which
um
uh Casa is addressed only because Casa
does its own training
yeah we do training for Guardian level
items but Casa does its own training it
does its own supervision and so
and I think the last I heard
in the full time in the 20 some odd
years the guardian that light on board
has been in effect we have had two
formal complaints against Casa Guardian
that lives
thank you We Have Heard
um
testimony and it is hard to know if this
reflects a pattern or if it's
idiosyncrat we just don't know
um that there there have been uh
occasions where
um
a particular judge favors
a particular gal and they establish a
relationship
um
that
might at least an appearance result in
um
the appearance of uh
uh unfairness or favoritism in terms of
what that gal
might advise
the judge
a bad is that something that you see
might be a problem
well uh
do I see it as a problem I guess no what
what I do see is that
you have a universe of guardian that
items
I think as we discussed at the last time
I was here you can't teach common sense
and
what happens is that you uh uh in your
particular and in your particular area
there'll be a limited number of Guardian
of items who want to serve your area
because for convenience purposes
and of that pool of those limited
Guardian Adel items you find that some
perhaps appear more competent than
others
or some appear to have particular skills
that would be better for particular
cases than others
so
as a judge you tend to appoint Guardian
Adel items in whom you have a great deal
of confidence in that will do a good job
and that means that some guardian and
items get appointed a lot more than
others
and I think that's pretty typical uh
situation as opposed to just randomly
picking guarding that items
um again in in the private
uh Arena
do you see a problem related to the cost
of a gal in that one party
or the other might be paying
for the GAO yeah I
um
yes I think there's it creates a problem
uh you do do I think that Guardian Ad
Litem has a obligation
to be independent regardless of who pays
yes
um
do I think it creates a issue with
regard to perception yes or I think it
it does create an issue with regard to
perception
that Guardian that litem
has a duty to be independent and to make
an independent ruling regardless
they think the I think
part of what the issue is is if one
person if let's say in a thing the the
one one of one of the parties either the
husband or the wife or the father or the
mother I should say in those types of
cases says no I want to have a guardian
that light him and I'll pay for the
guardian ad litem
well why would why would they volunteer
to do that they because they think
they think that
the guardian idea might look more
favorably upon them if if they if they
didn't think that the guardian item was
going to look favorably upon them they
probably wouldn't want to have one so
I think it creates this issue with
regard to
perception
that favoritism or bias
um
if I could just one more and then
are you aware of the practice in any
other states of um how the financial
cost of a gal is handled I'm not thank
you representative Macbeth
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
um so judge Gordon I wanted to ask you a
question that something you were your
testimony earlier about the family court
judges want to be there what is I know
there are some counties that have the
complex Family Division how many
counties have those and
how do you perceive that should all of
them have it is that working well
I have no clue I don't know the answer
to that hey thank you
um and then the other question I had had
to do with representative McMahon's
question or
um this um issue of irrelevant issues
coming into mediation or neutral case
evaluation could could you kind of
explain that it's it's really a Time
issue this isn't a evidence or Rules of
Evidence issue it's
isn't it that judges can only consider
what's in a statute so things that
aren't relevant to the parties aren't
considered but in a mediation or a
neutral case evaluation all factors can
be considered so it really isn't a
whether the Rules of Evidence apply in
family cases or not it has to do with
what the statute and case law says as to
what the judge can look at right well uh
even even when the Rules of Evidence uh
aren't applied aren't applied they are
applied they're just not strictly
applied in all cases and but the
the
uh
with regard to
the neutral case evaluation there's a
big difference between you know you have
the mediation and the and the mediators
there and they're just trying to have
people come together and they they're
trying to talk through the issues and
whatever else the one thing about the
neutral case evaluation is great is
because you know I can actually
tell people what I think you know uh
personally where where they ought to go
in terms of resolving their case and you
know
just yeah
just a case yesterday uh you know
fighting over five hundred dollars
um and say you know you're going to
fight over the you know everything that
came down to 500 and say if you're
fighting over five hundred dollars you
don't you you leave here today you're
fighting over 500 you're going to go to
your next hearing and spend two thousand
dollars at your next hearing so get this
done and which is not something that a
mediator would be able to do but the
neutral case evaluation you can be
really strong uh which I think is really
helpful you can you know you'd love to
be that way in the courtroom uh many
times
thank you
any other
questions
um
what happens
if the parties cannot afford uh in
mediation what would now be
225 dollars each
um we have three streams of financial
assistance one is the access and
visitation grant that we receive from
the board from DHHS
um the other is the ADR fund
um so one was established by Supreme
Court rule 48b that one we call fund
without kids because it applies to cases
without children
um and that if you're essentially at 200
of the federal property line or below
um and then the other is establish live
461 A7 and we colloquially call it fund
with kids because it applies for fun
cases with children and that one however
has a repayment component to it it has
the same standard of 200 federal poverty
line
um and there's a current bill SB 129
that will remove that repayment
requirement
so that all three streams of financial
assistance that parties can receive you
know there's not just one that requires
repayment
thank you any other questions
like you have oh yes one more here
thank you madam chairman thank you for
taking my question so I know that you
said that the cost for mediation was
going to be going up to 450 on July 1st
what is the cost of neutral case
evaluation
neutral case evaluation is free
thank you
the parties do have to come to Concord
consider that an asset not a debit
um
again thank you very much for your time
we might want to come back and ask you
other questions because we are in the
learning mode and we do very much
appreciate your counsel thank you
um
thank you madam chair Miss Duncan did
you
know
I don't know yeah I I think probably not
at this moment although if you have
something to say we would very much like
to hear from it at the moment we do have
uh some cards uh
and I think the first one that was
handed in was from Rebecca Hutchins
thank you
my name is Rebecca Hutchins I'm from
Dover New Hampshire I appreciate the
opportunity to speak I would like to
address the need for a parenting time
adjustment in our child support laws the
current laws do not take this into
consideration a little background about
me I'm a mom of two my son is nine my
daughter is about to turn 15.
we have a shared two two three parenting
plan my divorce was Final in 2018.
I had been the higher earner throughout
our 14-year marriage so I'm the obligor
in the child support calculation
high conflict cases drag on and on and
cost so much in the form of time money
energy and relationships it becomes
about money not about what's best for
the two families since there's no
parenting time adjustment in our laws
high conflict parents continue to battle
in court to squeeze out the last penny
they can
parents nerves are high our bank
accounts are low and we all want to just
be enjoying our kids
since my separation we've seen at least
four different mediators several of
those for multiple sessions we've never
reached an agreement through mediation
there was one time I made an agreement
outside of mediators and attorneys after
my ex's my ex lost his job
the agreement I made in 2019 was not in
my favor it was well above what I could
afford or was equitable
but because my anxiety was so high I
caved to avoid another another Court
battle I knew I just couldn't handle it
emotionally or financially and then also
continue to support two households in
2020 just after 16 months of making that
agreement I lost my job during the covet
economy I asked my ex for some Grace
with child support while I was
unemployed and he was working full-time
we couldn't reach an agreement outside
of Court seven months after I lost my
job the court did Issue a temporary
relief in child support
there wasn't even a conversation that we
could engage in about how much time I
was spending with the children because
I'm the obligor and the law states equal
or approximately equal parenting
residential responsibilities in and of
itself shall not eliminate the need for
child support and shall not be itself
shall not by itself constitute grounds
for an adjustment
in early 2021 we went back to court I
had just gotten a new job the highest
paying job I had ever had
I represented myself I had only been
working there for less than two months
when we had our hearing
at our uni as our uniform support order
was received about that same time I
realized I was suffering from complex
PTSD I also found myself in a very
incredibly toxic work situation I ended
up leaving that job
and yet I couldn't go back to court to
change the order
for the next year I made forty thousand
dollars less than what my order said I
made and I still paid over fifteen
hundred dollars in child support monthly
as well as the amount of our deviation
425 dollars monthly to direct child
expenses
in 2022 I tried to change our order
outside of Court including mediation
mediation does not work for high
conflict cases in this particular uh
shared parenting situations I've been in
another Court battle for over a year
trying to get my my support order
adjusted I've taken thirty thousand
dollars out of retirement to pay my
bills and to try to keep my credit score
from tanking as well as taking out a
second mortgage you can imagine what I
was feeling when my ex recently pulled
up in a brand new truck
it's a lot of background to help you
understand some of the high conflict
cases that are being seen in our courts
I'm here to discuss how the the current
child support laws don't support
co-parenting relationships in my case
this is particular for high Con in my
case and this is particularly for high
conflict cases and yet it is required
that divorced parents attend a child
impact seminar which encourages a strong
co-parenting relationship the New
Hampshire system both encourages
co-parenting and yet does not do so from
a finite Financial aspect it's both
confusing and Incredibly difficult to
navigate
the last four-year Child Support
guideline Studies have three have shared
three main recommendations we've been
talking about those today update the
guidelines tables to reflect the actual
cost of child rearing
increase the self-support reserve and
adopt a formula for Shared Parenting
that means for a minimum of eight years
it has been known that a shared
parenting formula is needed in our state
we need legislation to help shared
parenting families
my personal situation leads me to
support the need for a shared parenting
formula yet I'm not only interested in
solving this for myself I want to help
create legislation that's fair for more
than just my own situation
we need to work together to create this
legislation that takes these studies
recommendations into consideration we
need to come together to support
co-parenting and reduce conflict and
time and Co in court I'm confident that
we can create legislation that doesn't
divide but instead pulls parents
co-parents together for the betterment
of our children in Split households
let's get creative let's work together
if the law is fair for both obligor and
obligee in shared parenting situations
we can eliminate much of the high
conflict cases that bog down the family
court system higher earners won't feel
I'm gonna wrap it up
can I have 30 seconds
thank you hire earners won't feel taken
advantage of and both households will
have enough funds to support our
children I want to see legislation that
works for the greater good of all split
families in New Hampshire it needs to
start with the parenting time
adjustments and a livable self-support
Reserve thank you
thank you very much that was very
helpful and very specific do you have a
written um
uh copy of your testimony you could
share yes
thank you very much any questions
no questions thank you okay
um
that's there
okay uh Susan Duncan two minutes
thank you madam chair for the record I'm
Susan Duncan and I've had the honor of
serving as chairperson of the Guardian
Ad Litem board and I just wanted to
respond to your questions
um some of this came up before Ned was
appointed he wasn't appointed to join
the board until after he left the house
um there was a very tragic
um horribly conflicted instance that
happened with the judge who was
appointing a favorite Guardian Ad Litem
very good friend fortunately she has
been removed is no longer a judge the
board got a number of complaints about
the guardian ad litem during the course
of this
and and went through each complaint very
carefully
um and dealt with it by our usual
protocol
since this judge has been removed
there's been nothing else that's come in
regard to that case
um we do train the Guardians of light
them very carefully we don't get to
train the judges unfortunately sometimes
we wish we could do a judge training
because they're things that they could
do better to help the guardian ad light
them up optimally ultimately help the
families better
in regard to payment on the guardian ad
Leiden board we used to get a tremendous
number of complaints regarding payment
it's a very painful situation
it can be expensive even if the gal is
being paid sixty dollars an hour
frequently they're paid more it depends
on the case
the legislature in your wisdom put the
payment before the judge and this has
been a tremendous move because the judge
is the one that orders specifically what
the gal should be doing what he or she
should look at
uh what payment they're going to receive
and who's going to pay
after all of this has happened there's
nothing the board can do
when the case is over we won't look at a
case until the case is closed
the judge is the person who needs to be
hearing about the gal's doing too much
they're not going to see my person
whatever the the cases before that judge
right then and there and they're okaying
the bills
we do require that the gals produce
itemized bills so that both parties can
see exactly how much time they spent
visiting different people so when the
legislature put the the bill paying in
front of the judge and that he or she
has to sign off that was tremendously
helpful and I think it was insightful
for the judge to be able to be informed
on what was happening outside the court
those were my two points for my two
minutes
thank you very much you said you
wouldn't have any questions
thank you for joking
all right
um
Michael dynan
now just hand them here so that we can
wilcoaster
foreign
good morning Madam chair and special
committee members thanks for allowing me
to speak
try to keep this quick and what I passed
out was just some of the highlights of
what we've already been discussing and
to make good use of our time this is
somewhat of a summary of what we our
current uh if I could interrupt
um can you uh limit what you're going to
talk with us about today to information
that has not been given to us about
um a very
important case that has been discussed
and discussed and discussed very much I
want to provide that new information and
what uh representative Bickford and also
um Rebecca had spoken about is the same
thing I would say my name is Michael
dinen I'm a parent of two daughters
um here to talk about kind of where we
were but really want to talk about
what's been done so far as you may be
aware of the child and family law last
year we had one bill coming out HP 1647
also the Senate bill was Senate Bill 431
they kind of met in the middle they were
both kind of dissected by both sides
neither of them were able to pass each
other's
um
muster if you will so it was left with
kind of
um I think they were left into to study
into
um study but one of the things that was
clear is that everyone was waiting for
the last four-year report that four
report came out we've all heard it the
PTA parenting time adjustment was highly
recommended uh we're one of only nine
states that doesn't have we're one of
nine states that doesn't have it we're
still third highest in child support
paid the purpose of me being here today
is to talk about our current efforts and
what's being done
um representative Bickford
um representative Jim majory who could
not be here today because he's working
another bill we're working together with
some of the uh folks you've heard speak
already Greg Lombardo who's here today
who spoke before he's someone that's new
to this a lot of parents are coming
together and we're able to do this and
we're getting kind of sponsorship
because since 2018 anyone goes in for
their three-year review will be as I was
as I was told my decision came out in
2019 is that because of Silva no
deviations are being given all the
courts are strictly abiding by this the
the New Hampshire bar Associates is
aware of this so everyone and they go in
for their Theory view comes out kind of
in shock and says this can't be possible
well I'm here to say you know what are
we going to do about that someone should
do something we are trying to do
something so we're pleased to have this
this effort we have the nhla Mary
Krueger is joining our discussion we're
actually having a discussion this
afternoon we have some potential
legislative language written up already
that is called net the difference I
think that's what everyone agrees to it
uh is kind of the most common means of
coming up with a PTA parenting time
adjustment we are looking for the bcss
to I know they are not part of scripting
laws but to you know evaluate this we
want everyone working together in the
start rather than kind of fighting at
the end both SB 431 and also HP 1647
been a terrible fate
um we're here now and we are creating
new new legislation some of those
efforts I put in here identify them what
also is in the second part of that is
the Anderson V Anderson which very
clearly states the judge Supreme Court
said it is not our job to create
legislation or to create laws that is
for the legislature and that's why we're
here today and that's why we're all
speaking I want to be clear this is not
the previous attempts was met with a
little bit of a resistance from
different groups it often is associated
this is a dad's problem obviously
speaking today Rebecca and there's many
other mothers that are part of this that
are in the same situation they're left
with no funds to raise their own
children and what that funds means I
just want to be very clear about this
not to be redundant but when you don't
have funds available to pay for camps to
pay for extracurricular activities
clothing and sometimes these families
are in an Indigent state in the lower
earners left in a very interesting State
you don't have that means you actually
don't have the means of parenting all
the parenting because of Sylvie Silva
you can mention Anderson as well because
we don't have a PTA and very clearly
those two statutes 458 458 C one five
that equal approximately equal parenting
time or the oligar proving that there is
a reduction in fixed cost which is a
oxymoron you can't reduce fixed costs
they're fixed because that of those two
statutes there is no means of the higher
earning parent
to actually parent their own children
whether they even have them 70 percent
75 of the time so it's a very dire
situation more and more people are
coming to realize this everyone's in
shock when you explained what's what's
happening and how everyone's left with
no funds so I look forward to being if
nothing more than a conduit for this
information we've got a good group going
and I would hope that there's a means of
getting Senator Carson aware of this I
know some of the the are our working
group as it's being called
um working with Mary Krueger but also
even Governor sununu I think is becoming
aware of this as well so very important
matter and I welcome any questions
thank you very much are there any
questions
yes representative Macbeth thank you and
thank you for taking my question
um one I I think your testimony I want
to give you a chance to practice you
said there are no deviations currently
given in child support guidelines there
there are high amount of deviations and
that would currently there are a high
amount of deviations so I think the last
study this for your study that came out
there were approximately about 80
percent
um some of the cases noted was 80
percent of deviations that means that's
a deviation that was you know previous
to even 2018 but since Silva V Silva
there are less deviations there have
been less deviations
and you're talking about on that
specific criteria of equal incomes or
shared parenting I mean that is correct
okay so I just want to clarify that
um I guess um my question is I'm looking
here at um you know for the the statute
um regarding child support and the
deviations there are 13 or 15
considerations that the court has
um and one of them is the issue that
you're talking about it says the court
can consider if it's a If the child
support order is complicous story you
know if it takes too much money so I
mean and there are others here I mean
they're so was that issue brought up and
the court then and its judgment decided
that the order wasn't confiscatory in in
my case that it was not um Silva was
noted throughout my cases that there was
not in it's mentioned in mind
specifically and many others have spoken
and it's part of the study that just
came out is that even by itself is not
grounds for an adjustment or for
deviation so those the confiscatory
um whether you could measure that those
funds after mine was not part of that I
know many of the others are not they do
not take those other 13 into
consideration
I'm trying to answer but well actually
yes
so would you please provide us that
where the court is stating that it will
not take into consideration regarding uh
you know shared because it's shared
parenting can't be on its own so it is
appropriate and I would be surprised if
there is an order where the court says
it will not consider this numeral too
where it talks about if it is
confiscatory for the obligor so if you
could provide that to the committee that
would be helpful I'd be glad you and it
just to add to that and I think to put
the question in context so I'm
understanding when they talk about the
other statutes the ability to show that
the
um the children are living in equal or
approximately equal conditions in both
homes that is something that is not it
had not been taken into consideration
either so what often happens and just to
put some light on this the higher
earning parent because they're paying
the child support which ends up being
tax-free for the new for the home
receiving it the lower earner that's
tax-free income so that those funds were
intended to be shared across both
households now because of silvery silver
I think you've answered the question and
I think what you're providing is
subjective
um testimony well it is it's subjective
testimony because that's what's
happening with the courts and why judges
can't have a clear and concise uh
methodology or calculations they're left
it's the wild west right now I'll be
interested in seeing your order thank
you lovely
representative
thank you madam chairwoman and thank you
for taking my question you you
referenced that you had potential
legislation written up that was called
net the difference but I just didn't see
that as part of this uh where could we
get that
um I have uh Jim majory and uh
representative Bickford uh would could
have a copy of that as well it
um
it's an initial is that one of those
things where it basically states that if
let's say that the mom was well let's
say that the dad was ordered to pay
three thousand dollars and the mom was
ordered in the in the obligation
worksheet that the mom that the cost for
the dad was determined to be 3 000 the
cost for the mom was determined to be 1
000 if then the dad would be paying the
mom one thousand so that both would have
two thousand dollars is that what that
is the higher pays the lower yes exactly
and that's that's one of the
calculations that's there's about five
different that are used by different
states throughout the country there's
that's one of the five there's not the
difference there's a
um uh you know higher page the lower
lower Pace the higher and that's the
Delta
um but what I think is there's floating
scales whether you know someone has the
child 30 and 70 of the time I think
those things get
get
complex and confusing for a lot of the
people reading them the net the
difference is this version of it but
this is where we're trying to get input
from all of the the parties not just
trying to have something that that the
group thinks is effective or Jim majorie
or representative Bickford the previous
attempts 431 and 1647 were both very
close in their calculations that they
were trying to have accepted but neither
of them were able to kind of suffer that
cross analysis when they were kind of
dissected so we're trying to come up
with that language I think that's where
everyone's going to be end up focusing
to see if they're accepting of that is
those calculations what do they look
like and this is why there's five
different versions I'd say and all that
the study that that came out most
recently has those versions we're trying
to pick one that most everyone's
amenable to and I would ask as well if
there's a means of uh getting this and
I'm not representative obviously and I'm
just a father a parent but if there's a
means of getting attention to this and
so it can be worked on and get that in
the right hands I know that the bcss is
aware of it and I don't know how that
process works but thankfully
representative Bickford and
representative majority are both
sponsoring this as well
uh thank you very much if what you're
talking about is the um
preparation that goes into introducing a
piece of legislation that of course has
to be done by members of the legislature
and those members receive a lot of
information from the public and from
agencies and other sources and then they
are the agents if they choose to go
forward with
asking that appropriate legislation be
drafted yes
any other questions thank you very much
for your time thank you
the chair recognizes Anthony Kinney
good afternoon sir good morning sir good
morning
well uh thank you if you could just
touch the highlights um that's what
would be appropriate we have to stop at
noon and so keep that in mind
okay all emotions and pleadings uh case
summaries and transcripts are readily
available in PDF uh this case is out of
the Circuit Court Family Division Conway
this case has several irregularities
both from the family court as well as
professional and ethical irregularities
from the opposing attorney which are
being allowed by the court I would
answer questions on that but it's not
part of today's testimony
our family case has been ongoing for
three years and has turned into a very
complex case that shouldn't have been
it's supposed to be about the children
on May 4th uh on 4 11 2017 my co-parent
was arrested in charge of domestic
violence for hitting me case number four
six uh 2017
cr00430 a neighbor heard her hit me and
called the police
I had a hiring attorney to go in front
of Judge Green Hall to dismiss the
charges
this is again as you've already heard
from other testimonies in different
words the commingling of civil domestic
violence statutes in a criminal law the
straw man character not that you've
heard it that term before but they've
I've heard a testimony the judge used
civil law to take away my right then I
was charged criminally held it up bail
tried criminally found guilty by judge
Green Hall who had already recused
himself from the case for a complaints
for the complaints that another judge
found no civil violation for
my co-parent hired an attorney Leslie
Leonard from Cooper Craig the chant to
represent her with specific instruction
to take away my parental rights
and was told she would end up with
primary physical custodian
I appeared Pro Se this case started with
huge conflict of interest
on 618 2020 the motion for ex parte was
submitted
withholding visitation abuse and neglect
among other things and denied upon
objection through email by judge Leonard
on 625 2020 motion to reconsider ex
parte was submitted in denied upon
objection through the email
by judge Green Hall
on 6 30 2020
a second motion for ex parte was denied
upon objection through email by judge
betancy
on 720 2020 a hearing on motion for ex
parte was held and denied before judge
Green Hall stating that they had the ex
parte motions denied and we're not going
to take into consideration the long-term
effects of the child
on 7 20 20 7 22 2020 a telephonic first
appearance with no judge no recording
where my co-parent refused mediation
there's no record of it at the court I
asked
uh even though the judge read from the
notes of the first appearance not the
temporary hearing
on 820 2020.
so on August 20th 2020 the parties had a
uh we had our temporary hearing
instruction conference judge Green Hall
signing only what was presented by my
co-parents Council which resulted in
temporary order that put limitations on
the amount of time I got to spend with
my son
restricted contact
set limitations on visitation and
granted my co-parent soul decision
making granted my co-parent court
appointed mediation
per her request and denied my request
for a gal to assist with the best
interests of our son
as
certainly could not come to any
agreements together and further denying
my request for court appointed
counseling for my son which was already
set up by dcy after in their first CPS
investigation of my co-parent without
cause reason without facts proof or
evidence without due process without any
explanation none of these
recommendations
were adhered to by the court or the
opposing party
New Hampshire RSA 640 461 A2 because
children do best when
and New Hampshire RSA 641 A5
any order relative to decision-making
responsibility
joint decision making responsibility is
the best interest of the modern child
after receiving the temporary order and
without fully understanding as a
prostate lit again
looking to have equal time with our son
how all the weight was all my co-parents
favor or how I could already be losing
my constitutionally protected
fundamental civil liberties
the right to be a father to my son
I acknowledged that I was not being
hired as a pro se litigant in the court
on September 30th 2020 my co-parent was
arrested for multiple charges including
her third DWI the blood alcohol content
of a 0.215
after testifying eight nine years of
sobriety 30 days earlier at the
temporary Hearing in front of Green Hall
and which judge Green Hall showed
favoritism when having to convict her
with an aggravated criminal offense
State versus Christine Berlin case
number fourth 30 2020
cr00747 upon discovering a huge conflict
of interest to judge Green Hall and my
co-parents attorney Leslie Leonard had a
working history as well as a personal
family relationship attorney Leonard's
friendship with judge Green Hall and the
clerk of court Elaine Lowe
together in the past he was a director
and partner of Cooper cargo chant and
not only worked as attorney Leonard's
boss for her first six years
before becoming a judge now works to
sing a family court presiding over all
her cases
on March 23 2021 through Council
I mentioned I motioned the court again
to to an appoint a guardian item
due to the fact that petitioner my
co-parently is not following the current
court orders about communicating through
quote-ordered email and not attending
code only or Lucas was not attending
court order counseling as well as other
domestic issues
upon objection the to the GAO objection
to the GAO and a hearing on the motion
was set for June 15th then July 2nd then
September 20th October
I'm uncomfortable
interrupting you I know how important
this is to you but could you um having
given us this written text order can you
sum up for us what changes you believe
have to be made in the uh
with the functioning of the family court
sure right on the next page seven months
for our hearing on a motion for a gal
for a child who desperately needs
support
uh without question somebody confident
to look out for the best interests of
the Sun
uh
so you have this and you can continue
reading it I was refused I was refused
of everything from from the judge and
many times uh
my co-parents submitted a petition for a
civil DV order stating that I had her
six seven years ago after she was the
one arrested
and it was granted by judge Green Hall
case numbers in front of you uh
and that's where the commingling came in
I'm going to interrupt you again you
know we are not an appellate Corp yep we
are not going to make any uh change or
suggest any change in your case
the value of you being here and it is a
value to all of us is to help us better
understand
what changes we should consider
um recommending both to the court for
changes that they could make in their
procedure and to the legislature in
legislative changes that we could make
sure so that is that is what we need can
you give me a you know in the next two
minutes can you give me
um
any suggestions specific suggestions for
changes that should be made either in
how the court functions or how the
legislature should change the rsas sure
along with my testimony as well as many
testimonies that you've heard before and
I agree with uh judge Gordon uh the
inexperience and under qualified judges
uh that are are doing Family Court
should not be doing Family Court uh uh
and he's in judge Green Hall is one of
them okay on in on 2016 he had his
nomination
during a public hearing the transcript
is available for that too where he
shared his own experience with the
family court as well as answered
questions from the executive Council and
specifically questions from governor
sununu who was on the council at the
time about his bedside manners and pro
se litigants
he didn't have experience and he
automatically became a family court
judge
and so I I agree that
one of your recommendations is that uh
the court should not assign to the
family court individuals who do not have
experience with the family Corps I
exactly the way it used to be you want
to be a family court judge you got to
have family court acknowledge uh and
just like there's you know the training
for GAO the you know we just heard that
there's no training for a judge I think
there should be a family court judge if
you're going to make decisions based on
the best interest of a child my child is
being abused and neglected and it's
being ignored because of the conflict of
interest between the attorney and the
judge thank you very much it's that
that's very helpful do you have any just
in in closing out do you have any other
suggestions that you would like to make
um
foreign
supposed to be equal we're supposed to
start this case equal I'm supposed to
have equal rights unless there's a
reason not to they're making they're
creating this is called astronomy and
they're creating a reason for there not
to be equality but it started out of the
temporary hearing when I was already
being deprived of my rights
for no reason
thank you thank you and very much these
are all very very difficult situations
and we appreciate your willingness to
take the time to come and share that
with us
um
uh I I want to note again that although
there are only a few of us here uh those
who are in here are able to either watch
simultaneously this discussion or
subsequently
um
uh review it on YouTube or one of those
modern conveniences that we have now and
uh so that all of us will be familiar
with your testimony and with all the
other information that we have I uh
generally speaking I just want to point
out that under house rules we will not
be able to conduct
um
official business as a group in July and
August and so by the end of June we will
finish our time together that gives us
the summer to review information that's
been submitted to us and to consider
possible recommendations that we would
make and we would be coming back
together again in early September and I
imagine we will see
um many of the same faces then and again
on behalf of the committee I want to
thank you all for being here and because
we must adjourn at noon um I um
can I just ask one question while I'm
here not just for myself but for the
general public now we heard about HR 14
a bill that was just not passed and that
and it was never brought out the two
things the two reasons what it wasn't
passed it was just told that there was
two reasons it was in past is there any
way you could share that with us
I'm afraid that I'm not I don't know
what that was none of us are holding
back information that came from somebody
who testified and you might want to ask
that person what that was I mean this
was this is not something that any of us
are familiar with okay thank you so much
thank you very much and thank you again
all for being here